moving on
our main story tonight concerns home
renovations there are big commitments
that
always turn out great unless that is
you're on trading spaces in which case
they can turn out like this
we are in the room okay open your eyes
and see your new family room
wow
i'm gonna have to leave the room
wow that's a shame kudos to pam there
for being gracious enough to step
out she's showing a level of restraint
that those designers
very much did not because why is that
fireplace
opaque who would look at a sexy
flickering fire and say great
but what if it was blurry also that is
just too many candlesticks the whole
room is a windowless inferno waiting to
happen
it's deranged it's unsafe and frankly
pam deserved better
but specifically we're going to talk
about a way to finance
home improvements called pace it was
originally designed to provide
low-income homeowners
a way to make their homes more
environmentally friendly and to explain
more here is netflix's very own
barack obama we're making it easier for
american homeowners to take advantage of
a new program
called pace here's how it works if you
make the switch to solar
you can now install solar panels or
retrofit your home to make it more
energy efficient
at no upfront cost all by paying for
them
through the future savings on your
energy bills well that sounds like a
great program for homeowners
and by the way if you are under the age
of 35 let me quickly clear up your
confusion here
a homeowner is a person who owns their
home
they don't rent it the house belongs to
them like your parents
you know how your parents live in a
house but they don't have a landlord and
they don't have to sign a lease and they
don't pay a security deposit it's like
that
it's their house don't worry though that
will never be you you're not allowed to
do that
america decided a few years back that if
you were born after 1985
you don't get to own a house you do get
to rent apartments for the rest of your
life though
as you gradually pay off the student
loan debts from your liberal arts degree
that's the thing that you get to do so
if you're under 35
you can actually skip this story don't
even worry about it go fight with a 15
year old on tick tock about the coolest
way to park your hair
your life is sad and that's okay pace
though
stands for property assessed clean
energy and the idea originated in
california
as the brainchild of this guy cisco de
vries
the former chief of staff to the mayor
of berkeley who describes himself as
a capitalist hippie which absolutely
tracks for a guy whose name sounds like
he's about to gentrify jazz
there are actually two pace programs one
for commercial properties
and one for residential ones and we're
going to focus on the second one
where there are huge problems because
after a trial run in berkeley the
residential pace program
exploded across california in just the
second half of 2014
lenders issued 148 million dollars in
pace loans
and just a year later as more counties
across the state signed on
that number quadrupled to over half a
billion dollars
right now these three states have active
pace programs but plans to expand to
other states including new york and ohio
are very much in development and that
should be a cause for
real concern because when pace loans go
wrong
they can go very wrong take this
california couple who ended up
losing their home they say their problem
started when a contractor turned up at
their house
pitching a pace-funded improvement their
house badly needed a new roof
so they signed up i thought it was a
wonderful thing it's just really a
godsend one thing led to another once he
saw the roof he says well
looks like this wall then it was the
floor well i think there's some damage
there then a few months later
jumped our mortgage payments 600 a month
my life began to unravel at that very
moment
my thought is that we're going to run up
in a tent look there are some situations
where the idea of ending up in a tent is
exciting if you're going camping
for example or seeing the circus or
walking into the forest to finally
abandon society forever and live among
the trees
but it shouldn't really be the desired
outcome when you're just trying to fix
your roof
unfortunately the story of pace is a
cautionary tale about how good
intentions
were not paired with careful smart
design can
end in disaster and given that joe biden
promoted the program as vice president
and
promised on his campaign website to
expand the utilization of pace
it seemed that tonight it might be a
good idea to take a look at it and let's
start
with how pace works because basically
it's money designated for repairs
or upgrades to your house the average
pace loan is about
25 000 and repayment periods usually
stretch between 5 and 25 years
but the way you pay it back is both
unusual
and very complicated even though i've
already called it a
loan it's technically a lien on your
house a kind of debt
directly attached to your property in
which in this instance
you gradually pay back through your
property taxes
and ads promoting pace have like to put
that fact
front and center your house is actually
borrowing the money
and not you personally it's more like
the house is getting the financing
because payments are made through an
assessment on your property taxes
it's as if your house is borrowing the
money not you personally
okay stop because there is an obvious
problem there even if your house is
technically borrowing the money that
money comes in the form of property
taxes
and you pay for those your house doesn't
because houses can't pay taxes
because houses don't have money because
they're houses
it's the equivalent of buying a new
sweater and telling the cashier oh the
sales tax is on the sweater so
the sweater will pay that that's not how
taxes or indeed sweaters work
those ads are from pace administrators
those are private companies
hired by cities to handle the logistics
of the programme including
providing financing and approving loans
some of the biggest players are these
companies the largest of which is called
wygreen which is just objectively a
stupid name
it sounds like a contemplative jazz
album from kermit the frog
but the real origin of the name is
somehow even stupider
as a white green representative
explained during a local sponsored
content segment
why green i love this it's easy to
remember because it's actually energy
spelled backwards
exactly most people don't figure that
out but a couple reminders they usually
get it
yeah of course they get it because it's
not a hard thing
to get why green basically put about as
much effort into their name as trading
spaces put into pam's family room
there are a number of big flaws in how
pace programs are designed and here
is one of the first key issues while
companies like wygreen
may promote pace through ads and sponcon
segments
the majority of actual sales to
customers are done by
individual contractors who will be
performing the renovations and think
about what that means for a moment
the people with responsibility of
pitching a very complicated financial
product
a pseudo loan that's technically a tax
lien
are contractors whose training is not in
finance
no judgment here it's just people are
trained for different things
it's the same reason that you don't ask
a banker to regrout your bathroom tile
they're going to make a mess in practice
the way it usually works is a contractor
will approach you maybe
outside a shopping center or at your
church or even knocking directly on your
door and they'll offer to install let's
say
solar panels or a new air conditioner
with the promise of
no money down and that crucially the
improvements
should pay for themselves through huge
future savings
the thing is though contractors are not
always completely straight with
customers
about just how much their property taxes
could go up
they came to my house they said that i
needed the solar system that it was
going to dramatically reduce
my light bills when my properties taxes
came back in november
i had i went from 600 uh property taxes
to almost 10 000 property taxes which i
could not pay
600 to 10 000 that is
not good the only time the value of
something should change that
dramatically is if elon musk
shits out a tweet about it we truly live
in the best
possible system but also it seems pretty
unlikely
solar panels are going to cut her
electricity bill by
ten thousand dollars in fact for all of
the talk about how pace improvements
will pay for themselves there is a
fundamental flaw there
as this professor who has studied them
will tell you a foundational flaw of the
pace program
is that there is no independent energy
audit required of a home
before home contractors can start
suggesting all sorts of things to do to
it
some of these things are maybe put in
incredibly expensive high-efficiency
windows even though the existing windows
are not the main source of energy waste
and you would do much better just
caulking a few leaks exactly
there is no independent party required
to assess
whether your renovations would cut close
to enough energy costs to be worth it
which really seems like something you'd
want verified by a third party
it's the same reason that we have
independent health inspectors put a
letter grade outside a restaurant as
opposed to letting the owner put up his
own sign that says trust me
it's clean and that actually brings us
to the next
key quirk of the pace program because if
those energy savings don't
cover the additional taxes you incur you
could be in big
trouble remember those ads about how
your house pays for the financing not
you
what that means is your house is now the
collateral for the debt so if things go
wrong
you could well lose your home and you
know end up in a tent
and there are far fewer protections to
prevent that than you might think
because this is a tax lien rather than a
loan
the financing isn't subject to the same
consumer protections
that you would get with a standard home
loan so for instance in florida the
state
doesn't require pace providers to
explain the cost of improvements
check if the people who sign up can
actually afford to pay back the money
or if they even understand the terms and
pace administrators will insist that
they do all of those things anyway that
they're
diligent about vetting homeowners the
projects that they take on
and their ability to repay but there are
so many examples
of failures to do that thanks to pace
one missouri homeowner
wound up with 25 000 of debt
on a home that was appraised by the city
at the time at just
8 400 and if at this point you're
wondering
why on earth people sign up for these
loans it's because
they're often presented as a government
program one that remember
president obama promoted which might
instill a false sense of security
they did mention a government program
and that's why you hear government you
think this is an awesome deal
and you don't expect what happened to
happen
in a hidden camera investigation last
may we caught contractors touting claims
of government programs
so because of what you have going on
this this government problem could
actually help you oh that is a
government
yeah when we showed up the sales pitch
was over and they had some parting words
you sucked by the way look i'd say i
felt bad for that reporter who was
clearly just doing his job and was then
met with a man berating him from his
compact toyota but think of it this way
at least now he knows what it's like to
be a woman on the street who doesn't
smile
back and if all of this is starting to
feel potentially predatory
that's because it often is and if you
know anything about the history of
predatory lending
it will not remotely surprise you to
learn that an analysis
of one of the largest markets for pace
in florida found that many of those with
the highest debt burdens under pace
financing
were found to be in majority minority
zones and it doesn't stop there
because contractors have also been
accused of targeting neighborhoods of
non-english speakers
senior citizens and even those with
intellectual disabilities like this man
who as his lawyer points out absolutely
did not understand what he was signing
up for
it's very apparent from speaking with
him that he doesn't understand
these loans he doesn't understand the
contracts that he entered into
he had kitchen remodeling done and
he doesn't even cook he gets meals on
wheels he doesn't use his kitchen he's a
nice guy
he wants someone to talk to so he
invites them in he talks to them
and they talk him into hey you need
these windows replaced you need your
kitchen remodeled
look i get that you're on his side and i
do appreciate that but your client is
sitting right there
someone should at the very least have
thought to move that interview
outside the number one rule of talking
about someone behind their back is that
their back
should not be anywhere in your immediate
vicinity
and companies routinely defend
themselves by arguing that they disclose
everything clearly and the people simply
shouldn't sign these contracts if they
can't understand them
but that's a little disingenuous when
their whole operation
so often emphasizes speed over slow
deliberative consideration
these companies websites brag about
their super fast approvals or their
speedy approval process or make claims
like get approved for white green
financing in 30 minutes or less
and the clear implication there is you
can basically get your money like that
oh oh for sake i'm sorry
george
i snapped my fingers without really
thinking you know i'm busy
right i do i do actually what are you up
to right now george anything fun
yeah fair enough the point is though a
common sales tactic here
is fast approvals contractors often go
door to door with a tablet encouraging
people to sign
electronically and in one company's
video a contractor talks openly about
just how fast the e-sign process is i
just take the people to the
adopt and signs portion of it have them
pick a signature
assign all the remaining pages and we're
done in just a matter of minutes i was
in a house in rialto
patio door was open behind me the rain
was pouring the tv was on loud
three dogs barking four kids yelling and
we got through it and
i fell in love with the e-sign program
after that oh i
bet you did although i'm not sure look
how easy it was to get this stressed out
homeowner to sign a legally binding
document
is quite the flex he seems to think it
is there are indeed several things you
can do in a matter of minutes while four
children are screaming and three dogs
are barking in the background
you can schedule a grocery delivery or
have a tense eye contact only argument
with your spouse
or like an instagram post from an ex
announcing their making music now
then find that x's music on soundcloud
then
send that x's new songs to your group
thread then watch as they
mercilessly tear tevez's amateur edm
tracks a new
all of that can be accomplished under
those chaotic circumstances
but signing up for a massive lien on
your house from a guy who is in love
with his ipad
probably shouldn't be because this isn't
like agreeing to the terms and
conditions of an itunes update
this is like sitting across the table
from a banker potentially signing your
house away
the problem is the incentives just
aren't really there for contractors to
make sure
that the people that they're selling to
can actually pay back the loans they're
taking on
especially because in the final quirk of
this program that makes it so dangerous
the pace loan isn't just a lien on your
house it's what's called a
priority lien meaning that in the event
of a foreclosure
pace lenders get to collect their money
first
ahead of the mortgage lender or anyone
else
the fact that that's the case enables
companies like wygreen to bundle that
debt together
and sell it on wall street as a very
safe investment because
for those investors it's a near
guaranteed return but for homeowners
themselves
it can spell complete disaster for one
thing
it can make it much harder to sell your
house because no one
wants to buy a house with a lien on it
for tens of thousands of dollars
for renovations that might have been
done a decade ago if you are house
hunting
and you find that out it's like hearing
the realtors say here's the garage slash
meth lab or here's the basement where
the kidnapped kids were chained up or
here are the popcorn ceilings it
immediately kills
any appeal the house ever held and it's
not just
homeowners raising the alarm here that
priority lean placement
is the primary reason why in 2010 fannie
mae and freddie mac
stopped backing mortgages on homes that
had pace loans
and this is yet another potentially
devastating consequence
to a system with no real accountability
baked in remember that california couple
here is their contractor explaining why
none of what happened to them
is his fault did you as a contractor
though ever confirm
if they had the ability to pay because
this is a older couple on fixed income
they say there's no
way they could have paid for the work
that you took on in their house
i don't qualify people pace qualifies
people well there's a lot of passing the
buck here because
no there's no passing the buck miss what
you should do
is talk to y green who they had the
contract with
well hold on there because it's pretty
bold to claim
there's no passing the buck only to
immediately then pass the buck
it harkens back to that famous sign in
harry truman's office the buck stops
here with larry down the hall
he's the one who handles all the
paperwork you should really go talk to
him
the point is every player here is
perpetuating a cycle
of zero accountability the pace
administrator is playing the contractors
the contractors blame the administrators
and sometimes the finger of blame gets
pointed directly at the customers
themselves because here is where
legally i have to tell you that why
green which is
energy backwards by the way it's very
clever
insist that they have rigorous
disclosure practices exercise
robust oversight over contractors and
have never personally
foreclosed on a home they also insist
that that couple received
all the appropriate financing documents
and that they not
why green selected the contractors to
work on their house sort of implying
that it was all their fault which is
pretty hard to take
given that why green selects which
contractors it allows into its program
if your seafood restaurant sells tainted
lobsters
they shouldn't get to shrug it off by
saying well you picked the one you
wanted out of the tank
when they put those lobsters in there in
the first place
and companies are always going to insist
that this is just a problem of a few
bad apple contractors and that they are
always improving their processes
but i would argue the flaws of this
program
are baked into how it operates and no
one knows this better than tax
collectors
because they are the ones who end up
having to collect on the debts
homeowners rack up
and they can be the ones having to do
the foreclosures
just look at this missouri tax collector
begging his county to get rid of its
pace program just last month
i can tell you what the facts are going
to be the more of these that you have
some percentage of the people will lose
their houses and you can make the
consumer protections better
and you can make them a little more
rigorous but at the end of the day
some people will have their homes taken
from
them i think the bottom line is that
there
is no circumstance in my opinion
in which it makes sense to offer the
county's power to take your house
in return for getting you money to buy a
new air conditioner or a solar panel
or whatever it may be exactly
nobody in this country should be losing
their home because of an air conditioner
they should be losing their home because
of unexpected medical bills you know
like an american and all of this may be
about to come to a head if foreclosures
begin to rise in the wake of the
pandemic in fact one florida tax
collector has even warned
that pace will become florida's next
mortgage crisis
if we're not careful which is chilling
because the conditions are primed for a
disaster but it seems like we're not
doing anything to stop it
it's like how we inexplicably let
harrison ford continue to fly planes
we all know what's going to happen
somebody do something before it's too
late
so what can we do here well we could try
some reforms like
stopping door-to-door sales but the
truth is as that guy said
people could still end up losing their
homes the tougher question might be
whether or not reform is even worth it
because for the record
pace isn't even the only way that
low-income homeowners can get help to
finance
green energy upgrades nationally there's
the low-income home energy assistance
program and
the federal weatherization assistance
program or wap
as it's known to absolutely no one and
in florida and california specifically
there are several programs that can that
can assist
low-income households in energy funding
the point here is
if you your parents or anyone you know
is considering a pace loan you should
definitely see
if you or they are eligible for programs
like these first
and if you live in a county that is
thinking of implementing a pace program
with for-profit administrators do
whatever you can to stop it
because the fact is this business model
is fundamentally flawed
and i'm not saying that affordable clean
energy isn't something we should be
investing in it
absolutely is but we shouldn't be
putting vulnerable people
in a position where they are risking
their homes sadly this is yet another
example where a well-meaning public
program
has been corrupted by the presence of
private companies and if they come to
where you live
you would be well advised to tell them
to cuff foe
it's actually off backwards most
people don't figure that out
but after a couple of reminders they
usually get it
you